miss bulam weenie right now Amazon can
scan your face without your consent all
of our faces without our consent and
sell it to the to the government all
without our knowledge correct yes and
you know miss mr. chair I'd like to seek
unanimous consent on how Amazon actually
met with ice officials over facial
recognition system that could identify
immigrants I'd like to submit this to
the congressional record without
objection
thank you so much and miss Garvey in
fact it's not just Amazon that's doing
this right it's Facebook it's Microsoft
it's a very large amount of tech
corporations correct that's correct and
do you think it's fair to say that
Americans are essentially being spied on
and surveilled on a massive scale
without their consent or knowledge I
would make a bit of a distinction
between what Facebook and other
companies are doing but yielding to
missable and weenie for for more
specifics on this I will say most of the
law enforcement agency systems operate
on DMV databases or mug shot databases
so information that has been collected
by agencies rather than companies thank
you thank you and mr. Ferguson what are
the prime constitutional concerns about
the non-consensual use of facial
recognition recognition technology is
rooted or alluded to in the 14th
amendment correct it's correct is one of
them and and right now companies
government's agencies can essentially
steal or use your biometric data from
you without your consent and and this is
outrageous right because this is America
and we have a right to privacy isn't
that right miss : Cooley Ani that's
absolutely right and miss Kalyani what
was the Supreme Court case that
identified the right to privacy it's
been I don't remember the original one
but I mean there's been a series of
cases where the court has essentially
said look with modern technology it
shouldn't mean that we don't have Fourth
Amendment right yes and and what was the
was there a landmark Supreme Court
decision that established that that
we've seen recently you know we've seen
the carpenter case where the courts
that it was unconstitutionally
unconstitutional to warrantless least
surveillance and we've seen cases where
the court has also said that you can't
search a cell phone without a warrant
and it into arrest
more specifically with relation to the
14th amendment it was roe v wade that
established the right to privacy is that
correct
Roe we gave the right to privacy was
addressed there as well right so you
know we don't just have because that
that right to privacy is alluded to part
of the case in our right to privacy is
that this doesn't just give us a right
to my uterus it gives me a right to my
hand and my shoulders my heads my knees
my toes and my face and so in some ways
part of the case although it's not all
of it there's a great deal of rooted in
the 14th amendment with search and
seizure but in our right to privacy
we also see here that it's this is about
our entire body our right - our entire
body and the similar principle that
keeps a legislator out of my womb is the
same principle that would keep Facebook
and algorithms off of all of our faces
and so do you think there's a it's fair
to draw that connection I think that
when we're talking about privacy it is
important to think about more than our
face right so we're seeing the FBI use
things like voice recognition and gait
recognition all different types of
biometrics that I think fundamentally
raised some of the the same privacy
concerns that have been talked about by
all the panelists today thank you thank
you so much Enda miss balloon weenie I
heard your opening statement and we saw
that these algorithms are effective in
two different degrees so are they most
effective on women No are they most
effective on people of color absolutely
not are they most effective on people of
different gender expressions no in fact
they exclude them
so what demographic is it mostly
effective on quite men and who are the
primary engineers and designers of these
algorithms definitely white men so
we have a technology that was created
and designed by one demographic that is
only mostly effective on that one
demographic and they're trying to sell
it and impose it on the entirety of the
country so we have the Pale Male
datasets being used as something that's
universal when that isn't actually the
case when it comes to representing the
full sepia of humanity and do you think
that this could exacerbate the already
egregious inequalities in our in our
criminal justice system it already is
thank you very much I yield the rest of
my time of the show how so so right now
because you have the propensity for
these systems to misidentify black
individuals or brown communities more
often and you also have confirmation
bias where if I have been said to be a
criminal that I am more targeted so
there's a case with mr. BA an
eighteen-year-old african-american man
who was misidentified in Apple stores as
a thief and in fact he was he was
falsely arrested multiple times because
of this kind of misidentification and
then if you have a case where we're
thinking about putting let's say facial
recognition technology on police body
cams in a situation where you already
have racial bias that can be used to
confirm right the presumption of guilt
even if that hasn't necessarily been
proven because you have these algorithms
that we already have sufficient
information showing fail more on
communities of color problem